from the Tampa Bay Times to Santa says
Florida will not assist in possible
Trump extradition after indictment the
Florida governor weighed in on Twitter
he said the weaponization of the legal
system to advance a political agenda
turns the rule of law on its head it is
an American The soros-backed Manhattan
D.A has consistently bent the law to
downgrade felonies and to excuse
criminal misconduct yet now he is and
there's a second tweet here
where is it at
wait oh okay yet now he is stretching
the law to Target a political opponent
Florida will not assist in an
extradition request given the
questionable circumstances at issue with
the Soros backed Manhattan prosecutor
and his political agenda uh what are
your thoughts
is he actually sore respect
I think so or was it that like because I
thought that the actual thing was like
George Soros uh contributed to a pack
that has also contributed to him
I think it's a little different but
regardless even outside of that I mean
Rhonda Santos saying we're not going to
allow what is he saying I'm not going to
extradite right that's what I said well
what you know did he even really say
that he said well not assist in the
extradition it's like a pretty tepid
statement to be completely honest so I
don't even know if there's an actual
question to be asked should Florida
assist in the extradition like it
doesn't matter
well it kind of matters I think it would
I think it matters based on the
precedent of the crime if this is a
crime that they wouldn't normally
extradite for then they probably don't
have an obligation to right like I don't
think California would extradite me if I
had like an outstanding speeding ticket
in Iowa right yeah and this is this
might be a similar thing where they
don't actually but if there was like a
if somebody like did a double homicide
in Florida's like we're not going to
extrude at them that'd probably be a
pretty big deal but yeah I don't know if
we're crying like this if it's I think
we're Expedition is ordinary or not
Donald Trump what's the what's the
what's the charge that he falsified
um a legal bill
well it's that he falsified a legal bill
but it has to be something more than
that right because that charge in and of
itself is a misdemeanor that the statute
of limitations would have expired on so
it said he falsified that legal bill in
the commission or the experiment of
another crime I think it's related to
election stuff the argument was that it
pertained to campaign Finance or they
use campaign funds to do it or something
like that because Cohen build Trump
campaign or whatever but uh
I guess we'll see when the indictment
comes out if they're stretching us up to
a felony my my view is uh it's it's all
overtly political and this country is
being ripped and ripped to shreds so I
don't know if it really matters whether
to Santa is going to do anything or not
it's like whether whether we can have a
debate about it or not no one's going to
agree the end result is just going to be
people on the right saying that Trump is
being politically persecuted and people
left saying it's Justice well it only
matters for the primary because desensis
this whole time has been trying to
position himself As Trump without the
bad stuff that's sort of his whole brand
but as you go into this more and more
you're going to see that the census
really isn't a trump guy and he's going
to try and make his own brand of sort of
trumpism but with some other stuff and I
think a lot of Hardcore Trump people
like myself I mean I was a day one 2016
supporter right when he came down the
golden escalar as I was already sold but
a lot of people that I know in DC or in
sort of these other circles they think
oh well we should move on from Trump
it's time for DeSantis to take over but
I mean the reality is this whole thing
is only going to help Trump I think the
mug shot it's gonna be on t-shirts it's
gonna be our like people are gonna love
it uh on the left they're loving it
because they think oh we finally got him
we got the handcuffs on Donald Trump on
the right we're they're just getting
things in martyr can I can I play this
video from Dash dabrowsky yeah yeah okay
I think I gotta turn it down big news
Donald Trump has been indicted in
Manhattan the grand jury just voted to
indict Donald Trump for his hush money
payments to Stormy Daniels this is big
news
like if he's in control his moves when
he goes uh what has he uh been indicted
he tilts his head forward and he gets
Shadow under his eyes and looks real
villainous for us is it called the
Kubrick stairs back up yeah it's awesome
when it comes to stuff like this I think
it's really important that you mentally
swap the people out in your head to
figure out how you feel about it because
we have a huge problem right now in this
country with actually having principal
positions on any issue
whatsoever so I think that when people
are trying to think like should Trump
get arrested for this like think like if
it was Hillary Clinton would you feel
the same if it was AOC would you feel
the same if it was DeSantis would you
feel the same I think it's really
important to do these mental swaps to
check for honesty to make sure that it's
not just like you said like all partisan
politics at the end of the day
especially legal systems are involved I
agree but I don't think it's principles
I don't think anyone's principled at all
but I'm not saying that I am too I'm not
saying that from like a dejected you
know sense or like a not like you know
I'm jaded in Black Belt I'm saying it
that people genuinely don't understand
the moral philosophies around principles
and their positions so the example I
often give is
when it came to Florida on the parental
rights and education bill you had
conservatives being like parents have
the final say in whether or not their
kids are being exposed to the stuff and
whether or not their kids are going to
get these treatments the teachers have
no right to withhold that information
from the parents and then my response is
in Washington they completely agree that
the parents have final say so when the
parent says the child should get sex
change surgery the government should not
be allowed to intervene to stop it you
see the point the principle is the same
should parents have final say but both
conservatives and and left liberals or
whatever position have a differing view
of when it should be allowed
when it comes to a child deciding they
are trans the left passes law saying
they can withhold that from parents when
it comes to parents wanting to give
their children sex change surgery and
conservatives argue the state should
intervene to stop that so which is it
right
people don't have principles they have
moral foundations and they have lines
that they're willing to Cross or not
cross and so both sides will argue my
principle is X but it does not apply
that's my point sure so I do better I I
don't I mean I don't I don't I don't
think there's a do better or there's a
bad it's quite literally if two factions
of people have different moral standards
that's that's it yeah but I think the
problem is not being honest about those
moral standards like I think that's the
issue because when we're when we argue
for certain principles I think everybody
ends up at the end of the day we're all
attacking like the shadows and the
ghosts of the people that we're arguing
against because nobody actually believes
a lot of things they're saying and that
hurts our ability to actually move the
conversation forward like there's a lot
of people for instance I think I even
saw this on your Twitter I don't
remember the tweets there's a lot of
conservatives that hate it red
flag laws and now after this trans
shooting a whole bunch of concerns like
well should mentally ill people have
guns I'm not actually sure and it's like
what changed and that's exactly my point
yeah is that the principle the
principles don't apply to most people
left or right so
there are principles there you just have
to dig a little bit deeper so like for
some conservative spiritual just like
trans people I don't want to have
any rights um rather than like I don't I
I don't agree with like red flag laws um
and we just have to get to like the
deeper positions where they actually are
so we can fight against those positions
I'm I'm see my thing without red flag
laws is I'm completely in favor of them
so long as they have an adversarial due
process the problem with red flag laws
literally is that they're not
adversarial it's like someone can go to
a judge the judge can issue a written
just come and take your guns whereas due
process requires your your rights to
confront an accuser to file a rebuttal
to say no and then actually have a
chance to have proper adjudication so I
used to not be in favor of it until it
was actually conservatives who argued
that through due process your rights can
be curtailed hence like being put in
prison if you break the law and then a
Court gives you due process and says you
broke the law we can literally lock you
in a box and take everything away from
you and I'm like okay fair point in that
case if you're mentally ill and then
someone files a claim saying you're a
risk to yourself and a harm harm to
yourself or others then you should have
the right to receive a notice in the
mail answer that claim reject it and
then have a judge actually issue a
standard due process if you're in prison
you can't have guns you know I mean like
we we so if there is is some standard by
which we believe you are a threat and
you are going to cause harm then you
have a right to challenge that in court
same as any other criminal charge you
have and then if you lose and I think
that that is a defensible that argument
is defensible
but it's not defensible if it only comes
up when a trans person goes on a
shooting spree right so it seems like
this because there's a lot of arguments
against
um red flag laws that are still standing
that like those arguments didn't go away
like I'm I lean I'm probably against red
flag laws it leans slightly against them
just because I feel like it makes it so
hard
um if you're a guy that likes guns and
you've got like mental issues man going
to a therapist becomes really
scary because what if you get a
diagnosis that is now precluding you
from owning Firearms
um and now you've got to show up in
court and you've got to fight a judge
for your Second Amendment right which is
very important one in the United States
um that gets hairy and depending on how
people you know represent red flag laws
or what type they're pushing for
um
yeah it is a really scary thing but yeah
I'm just saying that that's a good point
that's a challenge it reminds me of the
uh it reminds me of the the do you guys
know BoJack Horseman yeah yeah it's like
that scene with the you know saying the
women carry guns and she's in front of
Congress and she's like well you know if
you don't want women to carry guns
because you're worried about what's
going to happen then you either have to
ban all guns you've got to let women do
and they like ban all guns like okay
well that's kind of what it feels like
happened with the transgender thing
um with the after the shooting because
they're like well maybe it is really
important that we look at the mental
health of the people that have guns and
like everyone in the left is like what
the we're like yeah of course but
well I agree I think if someone goes on
Prozac You could argue that they're not
mentally well for a gun if someone's an
alcoholic 25 of a Americans at
this point though yeah Pharmaceuticals
that's scary and there's another
interesting thing when I talk about when
I was in LA in Venice and you got those
guys selling weed cards and they're like
I'm walking down the street going to the
skatepark and this guy goes I mean you
get your weed card yet you get weed card
and I'm like no no he's like why not why
don't you have your weed card and I'm
like I don't need one it's like I'm not
sick and he goes oh you skateboard right
and I'm like yeah he's like don't you
like hurt your legs or whatever and I
was like yeah sometimes my knees he goes
oh bro you got knee problems oh you need
some meat you need some weed you gotta
get a weed card doctor will get you
signed up not interested you get that
weed card you smoke weed you you aren't
eligible you can't own a gun maybe for
physical pain you could buy you could
get away with it but for if you say it's
stress wait wait wait is that the Peru
are you saying it could theoretically be
true with red flag laws um on the form
it asks you if you are a user of
Narcotics and so the risk is if you have
a weed prescription card yes you are and
that means you will be ineligible for
owning a gun it's insane huh yeah so you
ever see the what do they call the forms
you fill out when you have to buy a gun
it asks you if you're a user of
Narcotics
and they have it classified federally as
a schedule one narcotic right it's like
the worst possible one if you have a
weed card I don't think you'll be able
to argue you weren't lying they're gonna
say you have a weed card prescription
like to do this drug there's no shot I
can't believe that I've never heard it
it's that's actually real that anyone's
ever had their guns taken away because
they had a weed card I've never heard
that I can see that argument and you
know what I know that's not the case
because if that was I would have heard
conservatives complaining about it they
want 100 byte and arrested over it
because he filled out a form and said he
wasn't a drug user when he's a crackhead
no no but that's
um that's literally why they want him
arrested for Hunter Biden Hunter Biden
filled out a form the form was released
publicly and on it he said he was not a
drug user despite the 4473 for a gun the
background check form for a gun
it asks you if you're a user of
Narcotics I feel like they wanted him
arrested because they said that he's
doing illegal dealings overseas where
he's roping his father into the
specifically for the gun issue it was
like his girlfriend or whatever his wife
threw the gun in a dumpster behind his
school did they accurately date the
crack use though for when he filled out
the form that was the question is the
argument he quit doing crack a long time
ago thus he was saying no and the
argument was he's like still a crackhead
they found a crack pipe in his car on
some time or whatever and so
I am not saying overtly and outright
every single person Whoever has a weed
card will never be able to buy a gun
again I'm saying if they want grounds to
take your weapons and you have had a
weed card they will come they will have
a a notice and they will say look you
have a weed card you're a user tell it
to a judge we're taking your guns
they'll use it as a pretext
we do it
for so many things are curious now so it
says oh well so it says are you an
unlawful user of marijuana so I would
say if you've got the card you're
probably not unlawful
maybe it would be you would you would
absolutely be they actually say on the
Forum I'm pretty sure it says note
regardless of local laws see what it
says it says that right
uh yeah it says uh possession of
marijuana remains unlawful under federal
law regardless whether it's been
legalized oh well government's
coming from iGun soon
this country is built on the back of him
man look at George Washington's eyes on
the one dollar really
although I will say I don't I've never
heard of like the ATF Crush referencing
databases to like ax guns from people
that have like legal marijuana cards or
whatever but they can if they want to
theoretically maybe thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time